21 year-old jordan spieth is making
history all over the place he's the
youngest US Open winner since 1923
thanks to his victory Sunday at chambers
Bay and he's only the sixth golfer in
the modern era to win the first two
majors of the year the Masters and the
US Open so the question now is can he
win that elusive grand slam which no
golfer has ever done in the modern era
and only Bobby Jones did once before the
current four tournaments were
established
jordan Spieth now joins us from his
hometown of Dallas Texas also joining us
on set is Bloomberg sports reporter
Scott shots Nick Jordan thank you so
much for joining us it's pleasure to
have you on we're all big fans here I
want to know what was going through your
head when you watch thank you so nice to
have you what was going through your
head when Dustin Johnson 3-putted the
18th hole yeah I was shocking I
certainly felt for him I thought that I
had lost the tournament I thought that
he was going to make that putt to win
and then as it sped past the hole I'd
you know I was just glad that I had a
chance that I had a chance to maybe go
to a playoff the next day and then it
was yeah when the next one missed I it
was a little bit delayed from the crowd
reaction and we were in this this this
tent so I you know I heard the crowd
first I said there's no way and then
watched watched on the computer screen
and saw that it missed I was just in
shock I didn't say much for about two
minutes and then realized that we had
won and and you know and I definitely
felt for him because on 17 I I did the
same thing but I added another hole to
make up for it he just ran out of holes
Jordan you are in rarified air now we're
talking about not since Tiger in 2002
has anyone won the Masters and the US
Open in the same year you're now with
Jack Nicklaus Arnold Palmer Ben Hogan
twice how does that make you feel
it's amazing yeah I mean that those
names are the the greatest to ever play
our game and you know although I'm
extremely far from continuing to be
mentioned with them it's nice to be off
to this kind of starting to be in any
category with those guys so the best
thing I can do is just to stay focused
on the Open Championship coming in four
weeks time and and get prepared and get
ready to go to the home of golf a
special place to try and get that third
one mark brought up Arnold Palmer he was
among the first to take up endorsements
the question I have for you is do you
regret signing such a long-term deal
with Under Armour because you're worth a
lot more money right now no I don't
think I am I I don't regret it at all
the the terms of our ten-year extension
at least the impact that it was made on
me was that they expected me to win
major championships that's the trust
that they took and it just went along
the lines of the same trust they took
when they originally signed me and I
when I first turned professional so this
is nothing out of the ordinary or
unexpected based on the terms of the
deal and and I'm just pleased to be a
you know helping grow that company and
we're doing it together can you share
some of those terms if you do win the
slam what sort of bonus money is in
there for you no I can't it's in my
contract I'm not allowed to disclose the
information have Jordan I want to know
when you look at your players games
sorry
many of whom are still living oh don't
worry what do you see in the way in
their game and their lifestyle that you
try to incorporate into your own
well a lot of what I look up to
especially looking at the greatest
players in the game is I look at their
body language in the heat of the moment
I look at how they're handling
situations they get frustrated when they
when they don't pull off a shot that
they're you know that the the shot that
they want to hit but the way that the
way that you rebound the way that you
deal with adversity in the in the heat
of a major championship is is what
allowed them to win it that's what
affected me at the Masters in 2014 when
I wasn't able to close and that's what
I've improved on and it has established
a winning formula these last two majors
was when there was adversity whether it
was Thursday Friday or even the first
hole on Sunday it's how you bounce back
and realizing the length and the
duration that one major championship
around kind of takes on you and that's
what happened Jordan we're gonna have to
leave it there thank you so much for
joining us masters and US Open champion
jordan Spieth